xavier moreau bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors une
nouvelle affaire qui intervient à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
américaine la maison blanche n'a pas
démenti le fond des accusations savoir
que moscou avait tenté de provoquer des
attaques contre des soldats américains
mais à la nier que donald trump ou son
vice-président a été mise au courant que
pensez vous de cet article du new york
times à l'écouté des gens propos
liminaire je dirais que les talibans à
l'origine sont une création un
instrument de la politique étrangère
américaine
en 1996 lorsque les talibans ont pris
kaboul madeleine albright avait dit que
c'était un nouveau pas vers la
démocratie
récemment hamid karzaï a dit qu'il y
avait des clans de l'état islamique qui
est en afghanistan qui étaient là
justement pour permettre de former les
combattants de l'état islamique donc
accusé la russie de soutenir les
islamistes puisque c'est de ça dont il
s'agit
en afghanistan est totalement ridicule
et tout le monde sait bien que les le
point d'appui de la russie en
afghanistan
c'est ce qu'on appelle annonce du nord
c'est à dire principalement les tadjik à
l'époque de en 2001 dans son assassinat
qui était dirigée par ammar shah massoud
donc ça ce propos liminaire ensuite on
assiste évidemment une fois de plus à
une affaire de politique intérieure
américaine et à une sorte de décor de
durcir gates puisque même si et bien
trump a été totalement innocentée de
toute collusion avec la russie il est
évident que les démons les démocrates la
gauche américaine va utiliser jusqu'au
bout là
c'est de justement ce cette soi disant
que collusion avec avec la russie dont
il s'agit est bien de porter une
accusation alors c'est comme d'habitude
dans les médias américains c'est à dire
que c'est une chose qu'on ne connaît pas
et une affirmation totalement gratuite
qui manière n'est pas prouvable ne sera
pas prouvé le but évidemment et
d'acculer donald trump et de le forcer à
prendre des mesures contre la russie
pour continuer bien à édifier ce fut
rideau de fer entre la russie et
l'occident
c'est quoi c'est déstabiliser justement
les relations entre washington et moscou
vient déstabiliser le président
américain qui est en campagne justement
je pense qu'il est les deux il ya les
deux évidemment trump sera accusé de
collusion avec la russie jusqu'en
novembre prochain
ça c'est une première chose même s'il
n'y a aucune preuve et deuxièmement je
crois que l'état profond américain
d'intelligentsia américaine veut mener
cette guerre contre la russie jusqu'au
bout et ça on le voit parfaitement dans
la manière dont systématiquement des
sanctions sont présentés au congrès
américain pour n'importe quel motif
contre la russie récemment il y avait
les sanctions qui doivent être prises
contre la construction de nord stream 2
et suit tard les réactions pour une fois
je dirais
musclée de l'allemagne et bien tout d'un
coup le congrès américain est obligé de
faire partiellement machine arrière et
il est évident que ce que redoute
particulièrement en état profond
américain est bien c'est que le les
etats unis se rapprochent de la russie
et si par hasard donald trump été réélu
c'est quelque chose qui pourrait se
produire dans la mesure où il n'aura
plus rien à perdre et ou retenter une
opération 10 pence man contre donald
trump de destitution pardon serait
impossible
est ce que justement des affaires qui
éclatent comme ça dans ce journal
américain on vous l'avait dit un des
informations infondées sans preuves
peuvent réellement avoir des
conséquences sur les relations entre les
deux pays
évidemment bien sûr de vue d'ailleurs
les toutes les attaques dont on sait
aujourd'hui qu'elles sont fausses contre
donald trump ont eu des conséquences
puisque donald trump n'a pas eu d'autre
choix que de prendre des mesures contre
la russie de signer les sanctions qui
sont décidés par le congrès qui est le
dirai à big man antirusse donc donc tout
cela tout cela aura des conséquences
et cette manière de faire des procès
médiatique sans aucune preuve juridique
on le voit en ce moment il ya le procès
du hem h 17
tout le dossier à charge du comité
conjoint sur les mèches 17 et épuisés
dans les médias numériques dans les
médias
dans les médias en général parce que en
fait il n'y a aucune preuve qui puisse
tenir de manière légale donc aujourd'hui
on est dans un système aux états unis où
il suffit qu'un article elle
recommanderait une fois des sources non
citées sans aucune preuve
avec toujours de ce qu'on entend depuis
depuis là depuis 2001 c'est à dire la
guerre contre le terrorisme
nous avons des informations il y avait
une intelligence isi on a des
informations on peut pas vous dire d'où
ça vient mais vous ne croyez sur parole
alors la question c'est est ce que les
citoyens américains vont croire sur
parole ce genre d'affirmation mais je
crois qu'on sort en novembre
merci beaucoup xavier moreau d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes analyste politique et
directeur de ce rapport